aujourd'hui il est certain de réformes
ont été annoncé un plan de relance a été
annoncé malheureusement depuis plusieurs
années il ya eu des planques annoncée
mais qui n'ont pas été poussées plus
loin ont réalisé pour plusieurs raisons
en bien sûr aujourd'hui le pays
malgré tout cette crise le pays détient
qu'on aime des ressources et à des
ressources humaines mais on sait des
ressources financières hors
hydrocarbures bien sûr comme les
ressources naturelles l'eau phosphates
il ya eu comme il ya eu récemment au
début de l'année la relance de desertec
le projet desertec avec un as en
partenariat avec l'allemagne et le
projet d'exploitation du phosphate avec
la chine